cette liberté individuelle que de
s'habiller comme au travail sauf comme
ce n'est pas une liberté fondamentale
l'employeur peut il apporter des
restrictions notamment si on est au
contact du public où on peut pas se
présenter en short quand on est dans une
banque par exemple et de la même manière
on peut avoir des uniformes ou d où d ou
des vêtements quand on travaille dans la
restauration rapide et c'est donc on
peut se voir imposer des vêtements oui
sinon la réponse est oui on peut très
bien venir en chantant entreprises dès
lors qu'on n'est pas en contact avec du
public en revanche il ya une petite une
petite contradiction puisque la cour de
cassation dans une décision relativement
récent avait validé le licenciement
d'une salariée qui en cas de fortes
chaleurs étaient venus plusieurs jours
de suite avec un chemisier très
transparent et la poitrine dénudée et le
licenciement avait été validé pour avoir
perturbé l'organisation de l'entreprise
c'est bruce enfin sam cooke été fait
dans l'émission mais là le gars il est
premier dock d'houphouet c'est un avocat
veille les avocats oui mais là
franchement ça va on parle d'un short au
travail on a parlé sans déconner que
j'ai veillé servir
bull alors oui je suis content le short
au travail c'est très important que
s'habiller convenablement ce
[Applaudissements]
depuis la crise sanitaire ya de plus en
plus de gens qui ont abandonné le
costume qui a trop de dérives et
aujourd'hui vous avez des gens dans des
entreprises très sérieuse comme dans les
banques par exemple qui viennent en
short avec des t-shirts avec des moules
de rome
si vous avez dû lire les articles
il a vendu coville oui parce qu'à mes
potes et les travailler aujourd'hui les
gens s'habiller n'importe comment c'est
un manque de respect pour julien ce kof
lcl
là où je rejoins guillaume c'est à
rejoindre guy n'ont pas dit oui suis
pour le fait qu'on puisse porter un
short ou une mini jupe peu mais c'est en
fonction de deux postes contre est de
remédier à ces six ans si on a un poste
au service où on au contact des clients
et où il faut un peu de tenue oui il
tenu à laon fait important s'est abstenu
de son cerveau qui ont eu lieu dans le
back office et barrières et qu'on
travaille au bureau et que personne ne
nous voit si ce n'est le collègue on
peut venir alors je dis pas comme si on
allait à la plage mais en tout cas un
peu plus décontracté je suis totalement
contre le charte au travail ça devrait
être interdit c'est irrespectueux pour
les gens c'est irrespectueux
l'entrejeu pour tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tiens non mais moi je vais vous dire moi
moi je suis pas contre tu me regardent
bizarrement n'est pas une fois des gens
comme les vôtres à la barre mais si mais
si tu es comme moi étaient des deux
types cannes toutes blanches
magnificence à parité manière
je te jure vénitienne à ma société par
exemple genre l'esm est un chant pendant
ce que je n'accepte pas cette débardeur
salariés qui bien qu un petit débardeur
un truc c'est pas possible c'est un
directeur de chaîne passe ou quoi
naturopathe avec un débardeur tu vois
mais un short ça me dérange pas plus que
ça mais encore une fois fois des belles
jambes et souvent c'est souvent les plus
moches qui se met le plus en avant non
pas une liste ça vous savez que gilles a
fait du naturisme ouais bah voilà tout
est dit
plus tard la note en battant
daniela les
buzz
internet apple regardez vous étiez en
short là au bureau est ce qu'on ne vous
respecte pas bien sûr que si ces
allégations étaient frères ne rentre
chez toi badges ont déjà 60 pas
messieurs vous le faites vous acceptez
alors bien sûr vous en plaindre et
peuvent même venir à ce combat bah non
c'est qu'on soit bien fait pas le short
nous loge pas quoi mais
là que mozilla de volbeat mauvais sur
tayac de
produits d'antan
grâce à ray koval ça ira ça j'y reviens
j'ai envie d'en faire un remix halak de
bolbec mob et l'agent semble tu veux ou
la baraque dans le vêtement la carte un
insecte et ouais c'est des vrais parents
bien sûr
olalalala y
avait des mots qu importe
excusez moi mais c'est pour le bien être
de tout le monde quand il arrive à faire
dans les 30 40 degrés ça ne
se fera pas mais par don mello résolu à
porter le short personne n'est choqué
parce qu'à dix matches de l'ormeau
président gbagbo tu
es moche tu te calmes mais je suis pour
lui avant bravo du rallye matière de
textile dont il disait sa vie
et n'a pas besoin que tu le dis que tu
le défends de basile iratni défonce
multi en fait alors il met en avant en
cas de des fonctionnalités comme en ce
moment n'au aucune pitié pour lui la
compréhension c'est à dire effective et
plus et inscrits ça dépend des métiers
si tu travailles dans une pharmacie si
tu as la banque et tout ça mais aussi
non dans ta boîte de prod le mec qui
part yves hanchar j'ai dit oui j'ai dit
oui la diva pas le manager des moindres
on parle dimanche entre selon des
critères parce que matthieu delormeau
dois dire on ne vas tu as besoin de te
mettre en bermuda toi va falloir se
mettre au vert me la mets
ta quête patronne
la raison elle emmène bidart non mais
j'ai pas évident pourtant je sais le
sait le bien-être des gens et quand il
fait trop chaud on ne peut pas bien
travaillé on ne se concentre pas bien et
donc dû donc après le short au niveau du
genou c'est ok je pense que tout ce qui
est au niveau enfin tout est une
question de centimètres c'est la
meilleure chose
tu vis très différent mi-cuisse nexus
one big ben à mi cuisse ça vous dérange
quand je mets ma short mi cuit mais
c'est pas du goût c'est carrément vous
ces sources
c'est pas sous bouhlal a voulu la peau
quand même un peu la boule sierra la
boucle
oui c'est un peu trop court ça peut
perturber des gens et tout mais je pense
que perturber des gens d'accord sur un
bermuda s'est passé on dit encore le mot
bermuda mais au niveau du genou droit ça
c'est correct pas mal soldats pour
mykonos
avans à l'oral à bouger c'est le style
qui revient c'est vrai mais moi je suis
moi j'étais en slip here mais non tout
ça
mais n'ont jamais très chaud je me suis
mis en chantier avaient acheté en
chipant vélo doit sa part est vrai très
bonnes gens s'associent pour vous à moi
sera ainsi parce qu'il est noir tout
simple à l'italien la magnifique tout
simple tous ces échanges écrits bah
ouais si benoît retour simple voilà et
puis voilà
boulot vent
oui mais après cela je fais d'accord sur
la mission
[Musique]
et
l'entreprise
boulot dans boulot vent de céline fillon
oui alors il
dit
avec delphine je pense que l'habit fait
le moine quand on est bien habillé on se
respecte mieux on est concentré et
regardez vous aujourd'hui vous êtes
super bien habillé
il est concentré
l'exception mais la règle